bonjour bonsoir cela dépend du fuseau
horaire dans laquelle vous vivez pour
écouter ou réécouter notre émission face
à la première qui comme toutes les fins
de semaine ne vous propose un débat sur
les idées ou la vie politique au sens
très large et non pas le sens politicien
évidemment l'émission face à la première
vague réalisée aujourd'hui par claudine
était le bl j'ai le grand plaisir et
l'honneur d'accueillir aujourd'hui deux
historiens pour évoquer le vaste et
complexe mouvement ayant amené à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans les
colonies françaises
abolition s'est dévoué d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui 27 mai temps guadeloupe et
puis en ce dimanche de fête des mères
qu'il me soit permis de souhaiter une
bonne fête à toutes les mamans d'ici
d'ailleurs et de plus loin
voilà c'est dit et donc aujourd'hui nous
inviter monsieur marcel dorigny à ma
droite un bon jour mais cette opinion
vous avez été confesseur d'histoire à
l'université paris 8 et vous avez de
nombreux articles et livres sur le sujet
des abolitions de l'esclavagé d'ailleurs
vous êtes arrivé avec deux livres sur
sur la question et puis à ma gauche
manque ses films au journal que ses fils
bonjour journal partis bourgeois mme c
dorignies bien connu de nos auditrices
de nos auditeurs et de nos internautes
professeur d'histoire géographie en
martinique actuellement chef
d'établissement et vous dont l'un des
thèmes de recherche ou de réflexion
porte sur le discours des esclaves et
leur place dans le mouvement
abolitionniste et donc avec vous nous
allons échanger sur en quelque sorte les
circonstances qui ont amené à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé dans les
colonies françaises certes mais ça ne
l'empêchera pas de parler si vous le
souhaitez de la façon dont ça c'est ce
processus s'est produit dans les
colonies britanniques dans l'économie
espagnole voisine des colonies
françaises
est-ce qu'il est exagéré de dire marcel
dorigny que tout a commencé à saint
domingue en 1791
ben tout a commencé oui et non bien sûr
l'insurrection a commencé à la fin du
mois d'août 1791 dans le cadre global de
la révolution française qui a bouleversé
complètement la donne qui a changé
complètement les données du problème
mais le processus
de contestation de lavage a commencé
bien avant
il a commencé en gros sur deux fronts
d'une part les révoltes les résistances
des états sous de multiples formes
je crois qu'on peut dire que l'islam n'a
jamais été content d'être esclave
donc il a toujours eu des formes de
résistance je rappellerai quand même que
le premier navire qui acheminent des
esclaves africains aux antilles c'est en
1503 onze ans après la découverte n'a
pas traîné à l'espagnol à la première
révolte connu d'esclaves
ces 1500 6 en trois ans ils ont compris
qu'ils n'étaient pas bien ils se sont
révoltés où ça se passe at révolte
l'espagnol a donc haïti aujourd'hui
voilà alors une faisant référence à août
1791 en fait c'est l'insurrection
dirigée par de typiquement qui était
donc un esclave et qui a pris la tête
d'une véritable armée on peut dire ça
des siens d'esclaves qui se sont
insurgés contre l'ordre colonial et dans
la nuit du 21 au 22 août 1791 ils ont
commencé leur campagne pour la
libération et ont donc assassinat de
colons blancs et 110 de sucreries de
plantation révolte généralisée
finalement beaucoup moins ne sera fait
prisonnier il sera défait militairement
mais même s'il est exécuté décapité plus
exactement en fait plusieurs de ses
lieutenants de ses soldats continuerons
la lutte on peut citer jean françois on
peut citer bien sous et puis un certain
toussaint qui se fera appeler plus tard
toussaint louverture et tout cela toute
cette insurrection aboutir à la création
de la république d'haïti le 1er janvier
1804 résumé mais c'est pour expliqué
marcel dorigny
c'est un survol tout à fait fidèle il
faut bien dire que la révolte de doute
91 n'est pas une révolte comme les
autres compte dans la nouvelle arrive à
paris on comprend pas très bien ce qui
se passe et puis au bout de quelques
semaines mois de novembre en gros moins
de 91
on a compris que ce n'était pas une
révolte c'est une guerre qui commençait
et on prend la mesure du phénomène
c'est pas une révolte comme les autres
il ya eu des centaines de révolte
d'esclaves ont la tasse de stress que
j'ai fait aux éditions entre monde à
cartographier les révoltes avec les
dates on a beaucoup beaucoup de révolte
pour good années où il y en a pas sur
l'ensemble de la caraïbe
ben là c'est une guerre qui commence
suivirent parce que le rapport de force
n'est pas le même et à 500 mille
esclaves à saint domingue
c'est pas la même chose ses fils oui oui
vous à se venger sur cet épisode
particulier il y a surtout un contexte
celui de la période révolutionnaire
puisque comme comme disait comme disait
mission pas si oui voilà la révolution
française comme disait mon professeur
jacques allet daid mais attendent
il n'y a pas de révolution française aux
antilles il y à une période d'évolution
nerfs il y à un contexte révolutionnaire
dans la métropole qui fait que qui
charrie percute aussi dans les colonies
et et ce contexte révolutionnaire fait
que les tout déflagration prend une
ampleur et déflagrations ce qui se fait
au nom des nouveaux principes édictés
par cette révolution française liberté
égalité fraternité et dont les droits de
l'homme etc
la déclaration des droits de l'homme
l'abolition des privilèges tout ça même
si les esclaves sont pas tout à fait au
fait de ce qui se passe et même si il
faut tenir compte du contexte haussier
de l'époque les nouvelles vont pas très
vite un la résurrection est apprise en
france quelques mois plus tard mais tout
de même il y à un contexte avec les
présents sur l'époque qui fait que tout
déflagration de prendre une ampleur
considérable et entraîne des positions
plus marquées on va dire que lorsque
c'était sous le contexte où le système
esclavagiste est beaucoup plus ancrée
verrouillé il faut rappeler que le
contexte révolutionnaire va se
transformer dès avril 80 doses et
surtout prête en 93 en guerre avec 82
c'est la guerre continental la prusse
l'autriche et que c'est des races a pas
grande conséquence sur les antilles
mais à partir de février mars 93 qui se
joue ce sont les puissances maritimes
qui sont en guerre contre la france
l'angleterre la hollande l'espagne qui
une forte présence dans la mer des
caraïbes
donc ça va jouer un très grand rôle dans
l'accession finalement à la victoire des
esclaves de saint-domingue parce que la
france de se retrouver
les colons français les défenseurs du
système vont se retrouver coincé bloqué
entre risque d'invasion anglaise parle
par la mère espagnole par la grotte
insurrection des esclaves révoltés des
collants haut ce qu'ils veulent et ce
qu'ils veulent pas le nouveau régime
évidemment les avons bénéficié d'un
contexte favorable
on ne veut pas l'histoire à l'envers on
ne sait pas ce qui serait pas aussi a
pas eu la guerre mais la guerre est là
et ils vont profiter et caen sont un axe
aboli le savage le 29 août 1793 au cap
il lance un mot d'ordre la république
vous à fait libres défendez la voilà on
fait des soldes avec les jeux c'est le
même processus qui se passe ailleurs à
cuba par exemple lors de l'insurrection
de l'insurrection la première
insurrection cubaine pour la guerre
d'indépendance le le statut des esclaves
le la position des esclaves est un enjeu
aussi bien pour la la la colonie le
colonisateur c'est à dire le pouvoir
espagnol où les insurgés
les insurgés blanc qui mène 7 7 7 lutte
pour l'indépendance et d'ailleurs c'est
très mystiquement évoquée par les
historiens cube est que manuel cespedes
avant de lancer son mot d'ordre
d'indépendance va à l'adema roi sonner
le tocsin et dire libéré ses esclaves
c'est donc il ya vraiment un enjeu et
dans toutes les lignes
les léopards aller c'est l'esclave est
l'enjeu de ces de ses luttes
d'indépendance marcel dorigny vous venez
de dire quelque chose je voudrais faire
un retrouvé noyé rapide c'est pas très
facilement vous dites que l'esclavagé a
été aboli ainsi nommée en 1793
précisions sur ça parce que
c'est un phénomène que l'on connaît peu
oui à face à face à l'insurrection armée
des esclaves qui se transforme en une
véritable guerre
le pouvoir politique en france
l'assemblée législative envoie deux
commissaires civile sans tonnac épaules
vers elle tous les deux sont entiers
sava liste on le sait mais ils ne sont
pas comme tous les antillais s'agisse de
l'époque partisans d'une abolition
immédiate radical brut a livré
l'abolition graduelle comme tous
confrontés à la réalité du terrain au
bout d'un peu plus d'un an de présence
sur place l'invasion olemps anglaise
pardon espagnol par la terre ils se
rendent compte qu'ils sont dans un étau
que la seule solution c'est de libérer
la masse servile pour faire des
défenseurs de la liberté et c'est le 29
août 1893 que sans en avoir le pouvoir
n'est pas envoyé pour sa sont onas
proclame l'abolition de l'esclavagé à
saint domingue l'abolition qui est votée
à la convention quelques mois plus tard
le 4 février suivant 1794 n'est en fait
c'est pas je pas minimiser cette importe
cette date extrêmement importante bien
sûr mais c'est la légalisation
la décision qui a été prise avant en
dehors de des pouvoirs en quelque sorte
qu'ils étaient prêts à saint domingue et
c'est tellement symptomatique ce que
vous dites c'est vrai c'est à dire que
dans le discours deux d'entre eux dans
son pub portu son discours à l'assemblée
nationale pour cette abolition de
l'esclavagé en dix ans donnons la
liberté dans les colonies c'est
maintenant que l'anglais est mort voilà
donc c'est clair que healy à l'enjeu
l'enjeu c'est bien se défaire de cette
étude c'est aujourd'hui que l'anglais
moqueries dans ton en savoie de la
convention ça veut dire que la première
abolition de l'esclavagé sous la
révolution française à 1794 est une
conséquence directe une conclusion
logique de l'insurrection des esclaves
de saint-domingue
bien sûr on m'a dit sur la convention se
retrouve dans une alternative
l'ap a trois solutions en a que deux
choix on déclare l'abolition de savard
est illégal il faut rétablir les salles
à saint domingue en contradiction totale
avec tous les principes de la révolution
soit on entérine on accueille les trois
députés qui ont été envoyées on prendra
commencer par la mettre en prison
rappel ces cinq jours en prison quand
même les trois députés de saint domingue
un don bailey on les libère il arrive en
grande tenue à la convention le 4
février
la leçon la seule issue c'est le vote de
l'abolition soit ils sont en prison soit
disant députés sont députés on accepte
le la décision qui a été prise en dehors
de la loi c'est pas le choix et on
l'étend toutes les colonies
sachant bien sûr que la grande décision
d'abolir le ca va dans toutes les
colonies françaises ne sera pas
appliquée partout ne sera pas appliquée
ici en martinique
puisque la martinique était sous
l'occupation ne lèse pas difficile à
comprendre que les anglais n'ont pas
appliqué la loi française publique et
celle là en tout cas et que c'est en
liga guadeloupe comment mais celles à
cette abolition est appliquée et en
guyane
car même à la réunion dans l'océan
indien les deux colonies françaises
l'océan indien c'est à dire l'île de
france aujourd'hui le maurice et l'île
bourbon il leur réunion aujourd'hui ne
l'a pas aidé à vue a boy d'application
parce que c'était très loin il refait
lyon brille une arme et on l'a pas fait
santini qu'il faut bien bien bien
constater qu'il faut bien bien établir
que cette abolition n'a pas parce que il
ya eu des accords d'abord avec les
planteurs les planteurs colon willoughby
oui à l'accord qui a été signé
quelques mois plus tôt de la boulie et
quelques mois plus tôt par rapport à
l'abolition
la première de ces novembre octobre ou
novembre
1781 1793 donc sont les accords de wye
trolls qui explique très clairement que
si l'abolition et et est donné dans les
colonies françaises
les anglais pourront venir occuper la
martinique et que les colons l'heureux
euros déroulerait le fath le tapis rouge
alors c'est là qu'il ya une différence
majeure entre martinique et guadeloupe
même si aujourd'hui on pense certains
disent que nous sommes deux îles soeurs
mais à partir de ce moment là il ya une
différence majeure parce que
l'organisation sociale économique n'est
plus du tout la même entre à partir de
1794 ici en martinique l'anglais les
anglais occupent la martinique à la
demande des planteurs alors qu'en
guadeloupe le
commissaire de la république applique la
nouvelle loi donc plus d' esclavage
qu'est ce qui se passe en guadeloupe
jusqu'à l'arrivée de napoléon on y
reviendra tout allait en de
véritablement différent par rapport à la
martinique c'est dominer en guadeloupe
l'esclavagé a été aboli
comme on dit révolutionnairement sûr
c'est une véritable reconquête militaire
qui est organisée révolutionnairement ça
veut dire que on a appliqué la terreur
oui on a pourchassé les poules du côlon
qui refuse l abolition ils sont beaucoup
sont partis beaucoup ont été prisonniers
exécutés cetera dans le cadre une
révolution qui était radical et
l'esclavagé a été aboli donc par la
force
exécutez notamment à la guillotine alors
on connaît tous leurs mondes alejo
carpentier qui décrit ses délicieux de
lumière de monter sur le bateau
il paraît qu'elle était dans le fond de
cale non la montée après sur le
continent sur l'île en amont tél alors
évidemment cette abolition
révolutionnaire de le salage va
transformer la société ou à l'hôtel
parce que quand les apaches sera
rétablie en 1802 beaucoup de ces colons
anciens colons sont marc son parti sont
plus là et il est seulement parvenu une
nouvelle soirée nous sont parvenues il y
aura des propriétaires deux couleurs
trouver terrenoire qui vont prendre la
place et l'état également qui aura un
rôle prépondérant l'état qui va
s'emparer d'une plantation à l'abandon
comme on dit en gérance marque ses fils
c'est beaucoup de ces plantes et en
guadeloupe est un qui ont fui ce bon
certains beaucoup sont venus en
martinique puisqu'on sait revenir
certains trinidad aussi et puis de la
louisiane en louisiane mais bon ils ont
un peu essayé mais ils ont même est
quelque part aussi à apporter
des idées un des idées dans dans ces
régions et c'est vrai que la société est
complètement changé en guadeloupe
à ce moment là alors 1802 nous allons
vite puisque bon si vous n'êtes pas
beaucoup de temps dans l'émission 1802
qu'est ce qui se passe napoléon 1er
arrivé au pouvoir en 1799 quelques
années plus tard trois ans après une
fois que son pouvoir il véritablement
bien j'allais dire stabiliser établi
décide de rétablir l'esclavagé dans les
colonies françaises
il est vrai que entre temps l'homme le
terrain s'est entassée a accepté de
rétrocéder la martinique à la france à
nouveau et donc là on a une autre une
autre
notre situation l'esclavagé rétabli
en guadeloupe puisque ils avaient été
abolis également mais y'a bien une
continuité ici en martinique puisque là
il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de pas de
rupture est devenu un véritable et à
saint-domingue
comment ça se passe parce que là
également l'abolition de l'esclavagé en
1793 est activée et elle est réalisée
mais que qu'est ce que napoléon fait
quand il rétablit l esclavage dans
toutes les colonies françaises alors il
faut rappeler déjà que ce qui permet le
rétablissement de l'esclavagé en 1802
c'est le retour de la paix la guerre
sévit depuis dix ans sur terre et sur
mer les préliminaire de l'ons donc en
octobre 1801 puis la paix d'amiens en
mars 1802 rétablissent la paix et la
paix sur mer dont la liberté de naviguer
entre la france et l'angleterre entre
l'angleterre est le dernier pays qui
était anglais les autres pays avaient
tous capituler avaient tous signé la
paix l'espagne c'est devenu un allié de
la france le feu est bas les alliés de
la france et qui te et la france
bénéficie même de l'autre par atik de
sanoma d'à priori cesser les hostilités
également voilà tout ce bon cessé de
l'ouverture des routes maritimes qui
permet l'envoi d'expédition massive vers
les antilles guadeloupe saint domingue
alors en guadeloupe on le sait très bien
l'expédition organisée par le général
richepance va rétablir l'esclavagé dans
des conditions tragiques puisque y aura
une guerre épouvantable qui va être mené
delgrès signa solitude etc
son héros sont des héros en guadeloupe
si l'on résister et sont morts alors de
grâce étant un militaire officielle
mauricienne le qui passait dans la
banque qui a refusé qui était le
commandant militaire de la guadeloupe et
15e de sa carrière d'aller en main de
napoléon vd comme tout simple comme tout
ça comme tout ça
assad à saint domingue c'est une autre
histoire en quelque sort et parce que là
le l'abolition de la sauvage a été
l'action le rejet de l'action des
estables qui sont dans un rapport de
force démographique sans commune mesure
avec ce qu'il peut et va en martinique
ou en guadeloupe plus 500 mille esclaves
ces normes et masse critique quoi voilà
une masse énorme une masse critique 95
96 % des classes dans cette société
surtout dans le nord
et le retour en arrière souhaité par
bonaparte est difficile difficile il
faut une guerre une guerre épouvantable
l'expédition leclerc propre beau frère
de napoléon quand même si aucun le
général leclerc général leclerc plus
c'est raté voilà je puis dire au niveau
de l'état c'est le beau frère du premier
conçu un pc le mari là la petite
caroline qui n'a que 20 ans qui
complètement inconsciente d'ailleurs
elle va elle part faire la fête à saint
domingue alain bon dont ce sera pas la
fête son mari est mort la fièvre jaune
mais le le relais est pris par broche
hambourg qui va mener la guerre
jusqu'aux vosges de la défaite des
tilles possible que la france gagne
cette guerre je vous rappeler un
événement on a une correspondance de
leclerc avec bonaparte fait un gros
volume quitter puis en 1935 une lettre
où leclerc dit à son beau frère
nous venons d'apprendre l'arrêté du
général richepance en guadeloupe qui
rétablit l'esclavagé il s'est arrêté
pour nous une catastrophe il va rallumer
la guerre des races
nous ne pouvons pas la gagner il faut
rappeler qu'en juillet 1802 leclerc
sommes en situation de rétablir l'ordre
l'ordre colonial toussaint louverture a
été arrêté expédiés en france le 7 avril
il est sur le bateau à ce moment là et
on pense que leclerc va rétablir la
situation il a réussi à diviser les
forces indigènes comme on les appelait
l'arrivée de manon c'est clair leclerc
avait toujours répété je ne rétablirait
pas les sauvages arrive lui vous à fait
libres nous maintiendrons la liberté bon
après il était sincère mais c'est pas
lui qui décide et on a une lettre aussi
de leclerc à bonaparte quand ils
croivent a rétabli l'ordre il dit à
bonaparte
si vous voulez rétablir l'esclavagé
envoyez moi un successeur moi je ne le
ferais pas bon bonaparte napoléon donc
beaucoup plus tard à sainte-hélène va
revenir sur la situation devant revenir
sur toussaint louverture et il a exprimé
un regret il va dire j'aurais dû
gouverner saint domingue avec toussaint
louverture week-end l'équipe elle
demandait que ça d'ailleurs faire de
coup ce faire de tout simplement façon
tous avaient établi un système qui petit
kiki chose qui qui pérennisaient quand
même le système le système colonial
colonial où il en est qui et qui
permettait à saint domingue
encore une unité productive on va dire
qu'on très très très prospère la ville
avait démontré alors c'est vrai que
c'était avec un système assez durs pour
les petits paysans haïtiens à l'époque
où il y avait tout
on va pas ici décrire ces deux lignes
peut-être plus le plus plus plus apte à
moi de le décrire mais il l'avait
rétabli un contexte qui permettait à la
colonie d'être prospère sans l'
esclavage et ça c'est peut-être ça que
bonaparte n'a par contre il n'était pas
très bien informé puis les il était
vraiment sous la pression du lobby
colonial du lobby des ports de l'aube et
des armateurs des planteurs qui était il
a eu une phrase qui n'ont ils étaient
excédés par les criailleries des colons
l'accord peut-être me lapp eaux
tempérées
il a fini par rétablir la savage est ce
que la décision était prise dès
l'arrivée au pouvoir
peut-être mais il a fallu du temps pour
passer à l'acte je rappellerai que dans
la constitution de l'an 8 du consulat
donc il ya un article qui a échappé un
peu tout le monde sauf la toussaint
louverture qui est très bien compris ces
fameux article 91 la concession deux
précédentes celle ci avait créé la
république du directoire avait assimilé
complètement les colonies ou territoire
de la république
mais transformée elle connaît en
département il est plus rigolo nice des
départements n'oublie sa première
département des relations c'est la même
loi même statut juridique que pour le
métropole l'article 91 inconscients de
leur huit de bonaparte dit désormais les
colonies sont régies par des lois
particulières le mont particulier on en
dit long c'était par lequel on dit ya
des flashes sous l'ancien régime
donc le comté juridique est prêt il faut
passer à l'as ce sera 1802 801 fin 1801
lui ils sont deux l'envoi des deux corps
expéditionnaire l'un réussir ou l upload
échoue catastrophiquement à saint
domingue
c'était pas possible et leclerc avez vu
nous ne pourrons pas gagner cette guerre
les créations à son son beau frère alors
accès fils
en tant que l'historien de martinique
martiniquais il ya une légende selon
laquelle napoléon rétablit l'esclavagé
sous la forte influence de joséphine sa
femme qui était une fille de planter en
martinique est vrai faux ben bout je
pense que comme je l'expliqué derigny
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça quand
elle s'est un petit peu plus compliqué
que ça et je crois que ça c'est une
forme d' instrumentalisation de
l'histoire
moi je pense qu'il faut rétablir la
vérité comme comme l'a dit possesseurs
de wii knee je crois que c'est surtout
les collègues les colons les colons ou
tel que lé faisait partie de cette caste
mais moi je crois que la vesle depuis
longtemps laissé derrière elle tout se
soit passé dans les colonies et sa
naissance et je crois surtout que ce
sont les amateurs de notes de bordeaux
de la rochelle qui ont beaucoup plus
fait plus pression et qui bénéficiait
plus du tri commerce triangulaire que
joséphine et puis quand on sait la à la
largeur com et et napoléon à aimer les
femmes
il avait une grande considération pour
les femmes
je ne pense pas que l'opinion d'une
femme puisse lui fut changé d'avis suite
au large de joséphine c'est un symbole
ici ils sont là bien c'est joli c'est
très bien qu'elle est décapitée place de
la savane
moi je suis allé à trois jours pour
faire une conférence débat à la pagerie
j'ai appris je j'ignorais que les ossis
décapité à la pagerie puis au moins la
tête dans le bosquet là où il ya le
petit buste il a plus de tête la tête a
disparu donc il ya une sorte de
d'acharnement symbolique contre
joséphine tascher de la pagerie passé
par boire n'est devenue impératrice bon
alors on peut pas réduire la baule est
heureux tablissements de savage à une
affaire de pression conjugales je suis
désolé on vous avait dit napoléon va
certain mépris pour les femmes une des
opposantes qui était anti tabagisme
madame de staël la fille de necker qui
va organiser au château de coppet tout
un cercle pour contester leur
établissement les sauvages il avait
qualifié un terme terrible aujourd'hui
on n'oserait
à dire ça de raisonneuse en jupon voyez
pour lui c'était le comble de l'horreur
réseau ne non seulement elle en jupon en
plus elle résonne l'horreur légende qui
n'ont pas fait historique autres autres
dit il ce ils se disent que napoléon
quand ce lock insulaires qui avait comme
a dit rice qui a choisi la france contre
la corse si je suis dit oh puisque
rappelons quand même que la france et la
corse plutôt a été la première
république le premier est la première
république du continent européen
bien en tant qu'avant la république
française dont une vingtaine d'années
avec le général pascal parrot ni
napoléon a choisi de devenir français
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'état
puisqu'il est devenu chef de l'état il
se dit aussi qu'il était raciste qui
n'aimait pas les noirs
est-ce qu'on peut l'affirmer la tester
en tout cas c'est un sentiment
relativement commun cette époque le
préjugé de couleur comme on dit ça comme
ça le mot racisme n'existe pas encore
le préjugé de couleur qui est dénoncée
nos monde notamment par l'abbé grégoire
qui va lutter contre projet de couleur
on verra schoelcher par la suite etc
je ne pense pas qu'il ait fait du
racisme entre guillemets une ligne
politique claire mais c'est vrai qu'il
avait un certain mépris pour cette
population d'origine africaine qu'il ne
connaissait pas qu'il ne comprenait pas
il n'était pas le seul loin de là et
c'est au début du 19e siècle donc sous
le consulat mais bien son qu'ils soient
pour quelque chose que commence à se
développer à se connaître à s'implanter
et ça durera très longtemps les théories
ce dossier anti fiq la dératisation des
races je crois que ces contextes oui
voilà c'est ça c'est un contexte je
crois que il faut pas vouloir traiter
les questions d'aujourd'hui ccd question
qu'on peut se poser aujourd'hui mais à
l'époque c'est pas le genre de question
montre que les questionnaires à la lueur
de jeu voilà c'est ça c'est à dire que
l'on veut on veut poser des questions on
veut poser des questions d'aujourd'hui à
une époque où ces questions ne se posent
et ne se posait pas vraiment pas dans
les mêmes termes
doc nous sommes dans face à la province
martinique la première avec une
conversation entre
marc ses filets comme vous venez
d'entendre et
c'est le dos me dit parlant sur
l'histoire des abolitions de l'esclavagé
alors rapidement avant de venir sur la
voie de paix suppose que la martinique
1802 défaite du corps expéditionnaire
français mené par le général leclerc à
saint domingue partie française quelques
mois plus tard en novembre 1803 la
défaite militaire est consommé et saint
domingue vent vers l'indépendance
donc la filiation de la république
d'haïti s'est volontairement a résumé
mais qu'il se dit manque ses fils que
cette guerre cette insurrection qui a
duré plus d'une douzaine d'années a eu
une influence sur les esclaves des
autres colonies françaises et
britanniques donc dans toutes les
petites antilles en fait à lui bien sûr
sa une une influence au retentissement
assez assez important et même longtemps
après après le l'indépendance d'haïti je
vous appelle pas semble que vous l'y
bolivar simon bolivar a par exemple va
haïti haïti va devrait haïti le général
boyer le président boyer je crois va va
l'accueillir et lui permettre de lui
donner les possibilités de continuer sa
lutte en amérique latine il faut pas
oublier haïti a été haïti a occupé la
partie pendant 20 ans pendant une
vingtaine d'années haïti a occupé la
partie la partie espagnole de saint
domingue et d'ailleurs jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on a encore les stigmates de
cette occupation dans les mentalités
c'est de là que viennent les dominicains
contre les haïtiens cette époque il il y
à il y à il y a en tout cas des racines
historiques assez profonde de ce racisme
envers les haïtiens aujourd'hui à sa
domaine de la presse que les dirigeants
haïtiens s'étaient sentis obligés
d'aller occuper ces deux avaient les
oreilles on donne une reconquête par les
français les espagnols de la nouvelle
haïti tout à fait et donc je crois que
si eric williams qui écrit dans
capitalisme esclavage que
conques que l'idée même le nom même de
toussaint louverture fait frémir dans
toute la caraïbe fait frémir les
puissances coloniales dans toute la
caraïbe n'est pas seulement parce que il
y à des révoltes d'esclaves dans les
états du sud des états unis en virginie
le mississippi au nom de la révolte le
saint domingue et au venezuela il avait
cité bolivar mais avant bolivar miranda
miranda en 1806 venant d'europe passant
par les états unis arrive en haïti est
passé un accord avec pétion l'expédition
de miranda qui va être un échec de 1806
par de jacmel la première exposition de
libération tentative de l'évasion du
venezuela à la plage de coraux en 2006
je me souviens parce que j'y étais le
président chavez a fait une très grande
cérémonie à la gloire de miranda le
premier libérateur du venezuela qui a
échoué mais il est parti d'haïti avec
des bateaux et des armes prêter les fab
four du film financé fourni qu'en fait
ils envoient par les dessins joue un
très grand rôle pour un triomphe pour
parler des hadjis marcel dorigny ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que une fois que
la venue d'haïti et pour clamer
personnel reconnaît évidemment puisque
c'est la première république 1
comme me disait encore la première
république noire comme on dit encore
aujourd'hui
mais au fur à mesure toutes les
puissances occidentales la hollande
l'espagne l'angleterre la france
finissent par reconnaître qu haïti ne
peut plus revenir dans le giron français
et que c'est un état souverain
mais les états unis ne reconnaissent
absolument pas l existence de cet état
car il faut rappeler que la proclamation
de l'indépendance d'haïti est
unilatérale il n'y a pas la moindre
négociation c'est des salines qui 1er
janvier 1804 proclame l'indépendance de
cette connaissance est de saint domingue
qui change de nom qui reprend le nom à
meyrannes et un d'haïti personne ne
reconnaît napoléon évidemment on n'est
pas bien entendu il n'a pas les moyens
navals de recommencer une expédition
c'était une catastrophe et en 1815 au
congrès de vienne où toutes les
puissances européennes sont réunis pour
régler le sort de l'europe post
napoléonienne il ya un article du
congrès de vienne ce traité de vienne
qui rappelle qu affirment les droits de
la france sur saint-domingue
haïti n'existe pas et il n'apparaît
jamais donc c'est une colonie française
dissidente
si la france veut y retourner elle a le
droit tout le monde reconnaît sur
helmand facile à dire dans les
tentatives de louis xviii donc d'envoyer
des bons ballons
peu importe ça va très mal se terminer
après on va négocier les conditions d'un
ralliement et sa s ur
c'est en 1925 que la france de charles
10 17 avril
milan ne se reconnaît l'indépendance
d'haïti moyennant une indemnité des
propriétaires de plantations
d'habitation etc qui vont être
remboursés par l'accueil d'haïti donc
l'avoir sont imposés haïti d'un pays une
indemnité qui sera versée aux colons aux
ainsi droit à leurs descendants et qui
ont perdu leur exploitation de propriété
voilà il est pas question d esclaves
mais nous savons bien que une
plantations sucrières main d'oeuvre
avons rien donc il ya une proportion
évidemment entre la valeur et le nombre
des save est jamais question d est là et
c'est seulement après 1825 que les
puissances européennes vont reconnaître
diplomatiquement éthique et c'est
intéressant de souligner qu une fois que
la france a reconnu le premier pays qui
se précise pour me payer un premier état
se précipitent c'est le vatican parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup de congrégations
catholiques est resté à saint domingue
et ici encore très fort aujourd'hui le
vatican reconnaît après tout le monde
s'y met mais les états unis vous avez
raison
qu'est ce qui empêchera la résine et a
bien su remettre haïti aux états unis
l'esclavagé est un grand débat et le
système politique américain donne au
congrès une sur représentation des états
du sud est ont fait un vieux le
territoire des etats-unis à ben harper
aux etats unis c'est treize colonies au
départ 13 territoires avec l'annexion
par l'annexion le rachat le louisiana la
france ces quatorze états
supplémentaires louisiane ses quatorze
états des états unis aujourd'hui du nord
du sud au nord bon 27
ils ont fait un dieu que les états unis
eau progressent vers l'ouest 1848 la
croûte
pacifica l'atlanta attaque à l'aliment
les deux tiers des nouveaux états sont
sous le régime des états du sud
esclavagiste donc la majorité au sénat
des américains deux sénateurs par états
indépendamment de la population c'est le
poids le poids du lobby je suis
majoritaire
abolir l'esclavagé aux états unis par la
loi c'est pas possible ce sera la guerre
qui ravage aussi parce que personne ne
peut pas reconnaître dans les aime les
représentants du sud 10 nous n'allons
tout de même pas reconnaître un état
fondé par des esclaves révoltés
on ne peut pas nous non des milliers de
stage chez nous sur les reconnais c'est
la fin de tout il ya des discours
absolument en classe politique au sénat
sur reconnaît ici on légitime
l'insurrection
on n'en veut pas je rappellerai que
quand même que en 1826 pas me tromper
date s'est tenue à panama le premier
congrès des états première réunion
internationale des états indépendants
amériques haïti n'a pas été invitée a
été le deuxième était indépendant
premier était indépendant d'amérique et
des états unis
cet espace 83 haïti sur le deuxième 1804
reconnu par la france au musée 25
haïti n'est pas représentée au congrès
le panama on n'en a pas voulu
tous les états indépendants nous le
nouveau et à rappelons le quand même
pour les états indépendants d'amérique
son estomac gist tous pour que les états
unis c'était un respect il donc ça
n'empêche pas les esclaves aux états
unis
dans le sud essentiellement de se
révolter de se rebeller de résister
évidemment le marronnage existe là
également comme il exige l'arrêt de
toutes les révoltes assez cinglante
sévit parfois donc un autre un autre
chapitre xi au relais l'importance qu'a
eue la l'insurrection puis
l'indépendance d'haïti qu'est ce que
l'on peut dire ça c'est le travail des
historiens qui peuvent interpréter les
faits parce que je me retrouve
nous aimons tous vers new talent nos
visions que toussaint louverture en fait
ce qu'il voulait c'est avoir une sorte
d'autonomie de saint domingue à
l'intérieur de la république française
continuez comment dirais-je
l'appartenance à fait possible
appartenance à la france mais sans
l'escalavage et finalement ça a débouché
sur les dépendances
est-ce que les insurgés haïtien voulait
véritablement l'indépendance ou est ce
que finalement ils y ont été contraints
vu leur résistance qu'il y avait de
l'état français en face d'eux je crois
que au départ
l'esclave veut la liberté il n'y a pas
forcément un projet politique spéciale
derrière lui ce qui ce qui lui importe
c'est d'être libre comme le système
esclavagiste lui a donné un petit lopin
de terre lui et c'est sa volonté c'est
d'aller travailler ce lopin de terre
pour pouvoir subvenir à ses besoins et y
vendre sur le marché le marché
je schématise je vais vite mais c'est un
petit peu ça disons lui il veut plus
être sous là sous la coupe d'un planteur
est d'ailleurs à haïti a eu c'est une
fameuse rumeur qui a couru pendant
longtemps c'est les trois jours que le
roi aurait accordé les trois jours de
liberté que le roi aurait accordé et que
les colons ne veulent pas ne veulent
appliquer c'est toi que les colons ne
veulent pas appliquer donc ya pas
forcément de revendications politiques
d'ailleurs le mouvement n'est pas très à
part la la la la
les quelques chefs qui s'est parle pas
là la force des événements en fait c'est
un mouvement qui se construit petit à
petit je pense souvent sous votre
autorité
c'est un mouvement qui se construit
petit à petit mais au départ les
esclaves se révoltent le 22 août 1791 il
ya pas même avec la la la celemony du
bois caïman
il n'y a pas forcément de volonté de
crayonnés indépendance notre
connaissance après que ça rien c'est ni
refera pas l'histoire à l'envers on ne
sera pas ce qui se serait passé si
napoléon pacetti musette idée folle de
rétablir de savage s'il avait gouverné
comme il le dira en 1820 dans son fameux
de mémoire de sainte-hélène gouverner
haïti face à demain avec tout ça en
l'ouverture peut être que bon peut-être
mais je rappellerai à donner peut-être
un scoop c'est un argument que j'ai
trouvé relativement récemment et par
hasard c'est que quelqu'un au moins ou
plus haut niveau de l'état français
avant même l'arrivée de bonaparte au
pouvoir c'est talleyrand talleyrand dans
une dans une lettre est longue et
l'ambassadeur de france en espagne afin
de la lettre ce n'est que j'ai trouvé
récemment dans les chais des
descendantes de cet ambassadeur il ya un
post scriptum de quatre ou cinq lignes
ou le talleyrand écrit voilà saint
domingue
c'est fini toussaint louverture à créer
un état qui sera indépendant
on est quatre ans avant l'indépendance
le talleyrand a très bien compris
talleyrand a misé affaires étrangères
oui mais rien n'a pas vu qu'il n'a pas
été écouté c'était ben hassine l'est
c'est un post scriptum un ambassadeur
les familles doivent savoir s'ils
allaient descendre actuel qui m'ont
donné la lettre en photocopies bien
entendu et le tête je vais le publier un
jour parce que quand même il est
cependant intéressant on voit la
conscience qu'à talleyrand qui lui-même
om ou même en appelant le quand même un
développe des projets de colonisation
nouvelle ailleurs c'est lui qui dépose
fameux discours qui fait la théorie de
l'expédition d'égypte on va remplacer
saint domingue par l'egypte la vallée du
nil si bien plus profitable c'est tout
près et sait plus comment ses plus
proches ses plus proches les
travailleurs sur pattes pas besoin
d'esclaves ils suffisent à travailler
ceux qui sont là c'est le relais c'est
extrêmement important que dans l'élite
politique française d'une action compris
que le stage allait disparaître tôt ou
tard il fallait mieux anticiper et
l'exemple de saint domingue est claire
il y aura le contraire bien sûr il ya
ceux qui vont dire je plus jamais ça
demain il faut réprimer ce qui va se
passer un peu par les états et les
faveurs finira par disparaître
on le sait alors il disparaît non
seulement en raison de la mobilisation
des abolitionnistes européenne
anglais américains qui luttent contre ce
système obsolète cette ignominie alors
qu'il en soit pour des motifs d'ordre
philanthropiques pour des motifs d'ordre
moral pour des motifs d'ordre économique
pour des motifs d'ordre politique mais
c'est vrai que les esclaves ne cesse
jamais de se battre de résister sabotage
empoisonnement grève marronnage n'arrête
pas comme vous le disiez mancelle domini
depuis les premiers temps de la mise en
esclavage des captifs venus des côtes
d'afrique de l'ouest en guadeloupe et en
martinique qu'il y à de très nombreuses
révoltes et je ne prends que les trois
principales qui ont eu lieu dans les
quinze dernières années de l'âme de
l'esclavagisme en martinique on à la
révolte d'octobre 1822 au carnet où il
ya soixante de personnes qui sont
interpellés le chef pierre sa suisse il
parce qu'il sait que c'est fini c'est
perdu pour ceux qui connaissaient la
plage du podium un peu avant d'arriver
au quart d'un descendant le mans 9e
trente personnes sont exécutées il ya la
révolte de février 1831 à saint pierre
et des historiens disent que la 2e
manche est dépassée far hills a dit que
les choses ont failli basculer à savoir
que la libération aurait pu être acquise
la veine de personnes sont exécutées et
puis la fameuse insurrection de la
grande anse au lorrain la noël 1833 avec
117 personnes jugées et là le gouverneur
de l'époque prétend que des esclaves
sont
en relation avec les haïtiens et donc
qu'il faut faire très attention dénonce
un vaste complot international donc
notre ses fils finalement la rivale de
saint domingue bien longtemps après
continue de faire des effets même si ce
n'est pas forcément vrai s'il l'a dit
c'est que je pense qu'il a plusieurs
documents pour couper pour couper
puisque vous savez il faut il faut au
moins trois documents pour attester un
ferme on sait assez pour paul
historienne mais ce qui s'il l'a dit
c'est que c'est symptomatique de quelque
chose c'est que ya quand même quelque
chose à fouiller de savoir si et quelle
relation pouvait exister entre les
esclaves de saint-domingue affalé les
libérer le saint domingue est issu de
matinée qu est-ce qui avait vraiment des
rapports ça c'est une belle question
pour une thèse par exemple mais toujours
est il que la question est fondamentale
c'est mieux quand on en esclavage on
veut se libérer et quel que soit le
contexte qu'il y assez c'est quelque
chose de naturel en fait je pense que
les auteurs du xviiie siècle ont bien
démontré
quand on est ce cas vont se libérer quel
que soit le contexte on essaye de le
faire et toutes ces révoltes dont nous
vous parlons oui préfigure mais continue
continue la longue liste des les votes
qui a eu depuis le début de l' esclavage
un donjon et celle de 1848 aussi celle
du 22 mai est faite aussi dans un
contexte après c'est savoir le contexte
dans lequel se produisent ces révoltes
et c'est ça qui détermine parce qu'il
faut pas se dire qu'il se détacher du
contexte général des choses alors celle
de vie il ya quelque chose d'important
en 1833 en bretagne finalement esclavage
même si c'est de manière graduelle et
progressive
et même si bradley qui sera peu peut
appliquer voilà puisqu'on ne veut pas au
bout de cinq ans par exemple à antigua
le gouverneur décide de le décréter
l'abolition immédiate parce que sinon on
y va surtout en version c'était pour les
colons mais pourquoi la france pour
autant de temps 15 ans je crois que
l'indépendance la guerre de saint
domingue l'abolition violence radicale
de l' esclavage sous la révolution va
laisser des traces très profonde
une véritable psychose des avant bras on
n'aura peur de seins demain on n'ira
plus jamais saint domingue donc on va
avoir peur d'affranchir prématurément
les estables même ceux qui sont contre
le stage je pense la plupart des
dirigeants sous la monarchie de juillet
sous louis-philippe traité contre les
ravages des abolitionnistes eux-mêmes
celle ci a cherché à n'est pas partisan
au départ d'une abolition une abolition
immédiate ici rallye qu'en 1840 42
points c'est très long haïti fait peur
je rappellerai une phrase de 1820 au 21
de l'abbé grégoire qui était un grand
défenseur d'haïti en correspondance avec
les dirigeants haïtiens boyer à l'époque
ouais grégoire a écrit une très belle
phrase aider haïti libre est un phare
qui éclaire la mer des caraïbes
l'espoir des opprimés l'effroi des
oppresseurs c'est beau mais c'est vrai
parce que haïti fait peur donc de la
france qui a subi de plein fouet la
sphère de saint domingue des anglais
c'est indirect et dans l'est à
l'abolition de 833 les consécutif à une
grande insurrection publiés c'est pas
comme ça c'est venu tout seul un bon
l'angleterre aussi avait résisté à
l'évolution des abolitionnistes avait
été battu plusieurs fois au parlement
là on passe on passe à l'acte pour
anticiper d'éventuels révolte et c'est
là un raisonnement sur le cher longtemps
on a peur des révoltes d'un second d'ici
on abolit pas il y aura des révoltes
rappellerai que l'argument des colons
contre les abolitionnistes
il disait voulait détruire le savage
vous allait ruiner les colonies qui nous
ruine et c est les corps évolutionniste
disait le contraire nous devons abolir
des ce lavage pour sauver les colonies
512 on n'a pas voulu on a perdu la
colonie parce qu'il faut comprendre
qu'il faut comprendre le contexte encore
général qui qui se fait c'est à dire que
les abolitionnistes aussi ce sont des
bourgeois ce sont ces s'est passé pas de
sanction de ce sont des il ya des
préoccupations économiques derrière
aussi et il faut comprendre que la
révolte même la révolution française
n'est pas une évolution alors il y avait
plusieurs tendances dans la révolution
mais il ya là
la révolution de gober spire yen si vous
voulez qui est très radicale et puis à
la révolution des grands bourgeois quoi
qu'ils veulent pas éduqué du capitalisme
peut-être pas les sens mais enfin dans
wii vous permet de rappeler dès les
années 1760 on dernier d'émergent la
naissance de la théorie des torts
économiques modernes nouvelle qu'on
éclaire à libéralisme la condamnation de
l' esclavage au nom de l'efficacité
économique
les physiocrates dupont de nemours
kenneth eu à condorcet bien entendu
pourfendre les ce lavage pour plein de
raisons morales et critiqué sa
économique déjà maté c'est le daily star
un écart d'au plus tard alain 676
prononcerait clairement une condamnation
économie de lavage donc c'est pas
surprenant que ce mouvement continue au
fur et à mesure que la révolution
industrielle se développe sa ferme
les nouveaux principes libre concurrence
qui berçait du travail qu'on sait
salgado le temps d'autant qu'on a trouvé
un substitut au sucre de canne et le
sucre de betterave qui viendra en 1830
en france le sucre de betterave a
supplanté le sucre de canne dans la
consommation donc le mouvement
abolitionniste en français divers et
variés entre les républicains parfois
extrémisme et dix ans un partisan de
l'abolition immédiate et qui en même
temps veulent renverser la monarchie
régime de monarchie constitutionnelle en
france n'est ce pas et puis des
abolitionnistes qui sont ici et
notamment les esclaves qui ne cessent de
sa révolte et à quel moment
est ce qu'il ya une jonction entre ces
deux mouvements le mouvement politique à
paris en france
on a déjà comparé zogby 7 qui militent
là bas ou encore victor ma slim nous
promet députés
qui sera élue miss à 48 qui est noir qui
était né esclave qui a été affranchis
plus tard je ferme la parenthèse est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui sont contre ce
moment-ci et puis ce qui se passe dans
les colonies voilà la convergence c'est
très bien incarnée par ce cher qui
venait de faire une grande tournée dans
les colonies rené est indépendant
d'amérique où l'avait vu un peu toutes
les situations il a compris que si on
abolissait pas rapidement une abolition
immédiate de les lâcher le titre du
livre les jeux le cher le publie en 1842
colonie française
abolition immédiate de laval il faudra
encore six ans pour que ça se fasse tout
s'est fait renverser le régime et c'est
lui qui va abolir les six conditions
n'abolit pas on va vers le gouffre
catastrophe il y aura des insurrections
partout et ce sera un contrôle âmes des
femmes d'abord pour des raisons
militaires dont c'est pour des raisons
politiques parce que l'opinion publique
en france ne suit plus le buick ne veut
pas sacrifier des soldats sacrifiés des
budgets considérables pour défendre les
intérêts des colons ne s'arrête plus
défendable que ses fils peut être que
l'achat se fait à l'occasion de notre
vin 2006 au final les esclaves qui
savait que l'esclavagé est aboli qu'on
attendait l'effort elle avait
l'information ne s'arrête pas quand
cette information cette décision allait
à parvenir dans la colonie donc
finalement cette insurrection sauf se
déroule dans un climat où on sait ici
que de toute manière laisse la régie
condamné oui parce qu'on a on a le
décret du 4 mars défaite du 4 mars est
arrivée on le connaît on sait on sait
que là et qui dit qu'un ultime française
ne peut plus porter de l'esclave donc
c'est clair il ya même la déclaration de
l'ue sont une déclaration faite en
créole d'ailleurs c'est mieux des
premiers extraits aux laiteries
martinique haïti on en écrit j'ai déjà
beaucoup d'aidé de la même époque
enfin peu plus peu plus tôt plutôt ce
que le directeur de l'intérieur
l'équivalent du commissaire commissaire
voilà c'est ça qui lui qui dit que la
liberté viendra bon qu'il faut attendre
mais eux
une fouille d'un problème entre
propriétaires et puis comme un esclave
comme un bon je vais vite hein on
connaît l'histoire mais c'est toujours
en toile de fond parce qu'on sait que la
volée de l'abolition va arriver et que
ça va dégénérer donc les les mulâtres
parce qu'il faut pas oublier le rôle là
dedans pour ipapy etc en tête qui décide
qui dit qu'ils essaient de kiki
convaincre le gouverneur au sto nom de
déclarer l'abolition puisque pour les
papilles devenu maire de saint-pierre
aboli l esclavage sur le territoire de
saint pierre avant que brosse roland
domaine le fasse sur le territoire la
valentine
mais ce qu'il faut ce qui est
symptomatique de choses il a nié que la
jonction aurait pu se faire mais bon je
crois il y avait quelque chose qu'on
qu'on peut lui dire qu'on passe au
silence trop les historiens c'est les
l'inimitié qui qui existait entre 17 et
puis michel cherche peut-être à
peut-être beaucoup affaibli le camp
abolitionniste
enfin c'est une première chose dont
l'histoire c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut de la place puis et puis deuxième
chose c'est que et je milite depuis
quelques enfants milite entre guillemets
pour établir un certain nombre de
vérités c'est que les esclaves là non
plus n'avait pas de velléité politique
séparatiste et c'est absolument pas et
répond devenir libre c'était la libye
est libre la liberté
en plus cette abolition donner quelque
chose que n'avait pas donné l'abolition
anglaise et que ne donnera pas les
abolitions il se passe pas dans le monde
dans la caraïbe hispanophone on va dire
celle de sites de la citoyenneté
française
ça donnait aux eaux à l'esclave le
statut de citoyen ce qu'on ne faisait
pas du tout l'abolition l'abolition
anglaise précédente
et ça ça va déterminer tout le reste de
l'histoire postérieure à mon sens mais
citoyenneté sera difficile à diriger
leur seule journée justement d'obtenir
les gaz aussi l'appliquer concrètement
si c'est juste de laisser l'armée gérer
cette citoyenneté dignité n'étant pas
appliqué comme il le faut ah ben ça va
déterminer tout le mouvement de lutte
pour l'obtenir justement absolument et
bien voilà c'est sur ces mots que nous
allons terminer l'émission mais là on
est parti pour une seule mission la
milice à 48 et en hébreu toute l'année
puisque nous sommes dans le 170e
anniversaire l'année pour réparer les
soirs mais je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui commencent à en avoir un peu
assez de parler qu'on attende beaucoup à
celle d'oghi vous êtes venu avec vos
deux derniers livres qui sont parus par
extraordinaire le même jour il ya mené
le jeu quelque temps tout d'abord dans
la collection que sais-je que tous les
étudiants lycéens connaissent bien petit
ouvrage de vulgarisation facile à lire
bon marché de petits formats sur les
abolitions de la première des deux seins
demain en 90 93 à la dernière au brésil
en 1888 et où les et puis vivre livre
d'art dit je vais dire plus compliqué
arts et lettres contre les slaves achète
un livre non pas une histoire de
l'argent serait bien incapable mais ni
fard par l'art c'est comment les
artistes ont joué un rôle important dans
la diffusion de l'information
disons le dans la propagande anti
esclavagiste et dans ensuite ans que
j'ai appelé la mémoire militante jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
dans ce livre il ya des oeuvres beaucoup
de voir reproduite 1,80 quelques du
xviiie siècle du 19e du 20e et les plus
récentes sont de 2015 donc très récent
des haïtiennes de 2015 par exemple mais
aussi des oeuvres en métro en france
métropolitaine on dit plus métropole
maintenant enfin à brest semble mémorial
le lait savage la presse date de 2015
il est grandir aussi fait 10 mètres de
haut
on le connaît peu mais il est là des
ouvrages à retrouver en librairie
bientôt merci marcel dorigny ancien
professeur d'histoire à l'université de
paris 8 plein des spécialistes français
aux deux langues françaises les plus
prolixes en matière d'histoire des
abolitions de l'esclavagé puis marc ses
fils professeur d'histoire géographie en
martinique bien connu nos auditrices de
nos auditeurs pour cet échange sûr que
j'ai un peu un peu d'histoire vocation
la véritable histoire des
abolitionnistes lavage en fait l'idée
c'était de replacer l'abolition
esclavage martinique dans un contexte
beaucoup plus globale c'est la fin de
face à la première pour aujourd'hui
l'émission été réalisée par claudine est
elle bien je vous souhaite à toutes et à
tous si on doit toutes les mamans un
excellent appétit à bientôt
face à la première